♪ ♪>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HAPPY THURSDAY.
LIKE ALL SORORITY GIRL
NARCISSISTS, THERE'S NOTHING THE
14TH CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT IN
NEW YORK THAN GIVING YOURSELF
NICKNAMES.
SANDY CORTEZ, WE STILL CALL HER
THAT, OF ALL HER PSEUDONYMS IF
IT'S THE BEST.
THEN SHE GOT TO CONGRESS AND
CALLED HERSELF ALEXANDRIA, CO
CORTEZ.
AND YOU PICTURE ONE OF CHE
GUEVARA WAS MISTRESSES ON A
MOTORCYCLE.
THEN SHE STARTED GOING AS AOC,
QUEEN OF TIKTOK E THEN SHE HAD
STILL ANOTHER NAME.
DURING THE 2018 DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY, WHERE SHE BEAT JOE
CRAWLEY FOR BEING WHITE, SHE
WENT BY ALEX.
YOUR FAVORITE GENDER NONSPECIFIC
BARTENDER.
ALEX.
ON HER CAMPAIGN WEBSITE SAID
WHAT SHE BELIEVED.
QUOTE ALEX BELIEVES WE SHOULD IN
THE FOREVER WAR BY BRINGING OUR
TROOPS HOME AND STOP THE BOMBING
THAT PERPETUATES THE CYCLE OF
TERRORISM.
FEW PEOPLE NOTICE THIS BECAUSE
FOR A SELF-DESCRIBED IS
PROGRESSIVE IT DIDN'T SEEM SO
SURPRISING.
AND WHEN SHE BEAT CARLY IN THE
PRIMARY THE STATEMENT WAS STILL
ON HER WEBSITE.
BUT THEN IT DISAPPEARED.
A JOURNALIST NAMED SAMIR KHAN
NOTICED IT.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE ANTIWAR
PART?
BUT BY NOW SHE HAD MORPHED INTO
ALEXANDRIA BOCCACCIO CORTEZ.
WHO KNOWS WHAT HAPPENED TO IT?
THERE MIGHT BE MORE TO THE
STORY, SHE ASKED AT THE TIME.
HOW LONG WILL WE BE MOANING
ABOUT SINGLE PAYER WHEN THIS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR NUCLEAR
ARMAGEDDON BENCHMARK THAT ENDED
UP BEING A PRETTY GOOD QUESTION,
NOT EVEN A RHETORICAL QUESTION
ANYMORE.
LIKE BIDEN SAID, NUCLEAR
ARMAGEDDON ON THE WAY!
CONGRESS SAID NOTHING WHICH IS
TO SAY THEY BACKED HIM UP.
AND ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
STAYED COMPLETELY SILENT.
AND THAT'S THE POINT.
MAYBE YOU DON'T CARE WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE PROGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT IF YOU'RE WATCHING THIS
SHOW, THEY'RE MOSTLY RASTAFARIAN
CLOWNS.
THAT'S WHO THEY ARE.
BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT OVER
TIME, PEOPLE LIKE THIS CAN BE
USEFUL.
SOMETIMES YOU WANT PRINCIPLED
PEOPLE TAKING PRINCIPLED
POSITIONS.
IT KEEPS THE SYSTEM IN BALANCE,
YOU NEED THAT.
NOT EVERYONE CAN BE A MERCENARY.
OTHERWISE, YOU HAVE WHAT WE HAVE
NOW COME OVER JUST TO INSANITY.
AN IRONCLAD CONSENSUS IN
WASHINGTON THAT WE SOMEHOW HAVE
A MORAL OBLIGATION TO DESTROY
OURSELVES AND OUR CHILDREN'S
FUTURE AND AN UTTERLY POINTLESS
WAR AGAINST RUSSIA.
WHAT MARK EVERYONE SEEMS TO
THINK THAT.
AND WE NEED EVERYONE ON BOTH
SIDES, FROM NANCY PELOSI TO
JONI ERNST AND EVERYONE IN
BETWEEN.
AND THAT'S A HUGE PROBLEM
BECAUSE IT'S INSANE.
SOMEONE NEEDS TO SAY IT'S THIS
ACADEMIC INSANE OUT LOUD.
YOU MAY DESPISE, WE DO, WE SAY
SO OFTEN, BUT AT CERTAIN KEY
MOMENTS PEOPLE LIKE THAT HAVE A
ROLE.
THEY STAND UP AND TELL THE
ESSENTIAL TRUTH.
NO, WE SHOULD NOT GO TO WAR WITH
RUSSIA.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
IT'S LUNACY.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT CORTEZ IS
DOING RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S
BECAUSE SHE'S NOT WHAT SHE
CLAIMS TO BE.
SHE MAY HATE WHITE PEOPLE BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN SHE'S
PROGRESSIVE OR LIBERAL.
SHE IS THE OPPOSITE.
JUST ANOTHER STOOGE LIKE
JOE BIDEN OR KAMALA HARRIS.
A WILLING TOOL OF SOLOS
CORPORATE POWER WHO WILL ALWAYS
SIDE WITH JPMORGAN AGAINST THE
WORKING PEOPLE SHE CLAIMS TO
REPRESENT.
HUNDO SUBJECT IS THIS MORE
GLARINGLY OBVIOUS THAN UKRAINE
NOR, WHICH PROVIDES NO BENEFIT
TO HER, HER EX CONSTITUENTS, OR
THE NORMAL AMERICAN.
THAT'S ALL DOWNSIDE FOR HER.
LAST NIGHT OF THE SPARSELY
ATTENDED TOWN HALL IN THE BRONX,
TWO OF HER CONSTITUENTS SET OUT
LOUD.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN, NONE OF THIS
MATTERS UNLESS THERE IS A
NUCLEAR WAR.
YOU VOTED TO SEND ARMS AND
WEAPONS TO UKRAINE.
SHE HAS LEFT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
OKAY?
YOU RAN AS AN OUTSIDER.
BUT YOU'VE BEEN VOTING IN FAVOR
OF THIS WORK.
YOUR VOTING TO START
WORLD WAR III!
WHY ARE YOU PLAYING WITH THE
LIVES OF AMERICANS?
YOU'RE PLAYING WITH OUR LIVES.
>> THERE WILL BE NO NEIGHBORS IF
THERE'S A NUCLEAR BOMB.
YOU VOTED TO MOBILIZE AND SEND
WEAPONS TO UKRAINIAN.
YOUR PROGRESSIVE SOCIALIST.
YOU'VE DONE NOTHING!
TULSI GABBARD HAS SHOWN GOD'S
WHERE YOU HAVE SHOWN COWARDICE.
I BELIEVED IN YOU AND YOU BECAME
THE VERY THING YOU SOUGHT TO
FIGHT AGAINST.
THAT'S WHAT YOU BECOME.
YOU ARE THE ESTABLISHMENT AND
YOU ARE THE REASON WHY EVERYONE
WILL END UP IN A NUCLEAR WAR
UNLESS YOU CHOOSE TO STAND UP
RIGHT NOW AND DEMAND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY!
YOU CONTINUE TO FUND THIS
NUCLEAR WAR, THAT'S WHAT'S GOING
ON.
WHY NOT RIGHT NOW?
>> BECAUSE YOU'RE RUDE.
>> YOU'RE THE LIAR HERE!
>> Tucker: THOSE ARE ACTUAL
PROGRESSIVES.
NO DOUBT ON VIRTUALLY ANY OTHER
ISSUE WE WOULDN'T AGREE WITH
THEM.
BUT ON THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE,
WHICH DOES MATTER, THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
SANDY CORTEZ IS NOT A RADICAL,
NOT PROGRESSIVE, SHE'S A NEOCON
RED JUST LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE.
SHE IS A TOOL THE PEOPLE WITH
POWER, OBVIOUSLY.
THEY CAN SEE THAT CLEARLY
BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
HER RESPONSE?
>> YOU'RE BEING RUDE!
SAYS THE SAME SANDY CORTEZ WHO
ENCOURAGED ACTIVISTS TO
TERRORIZE THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
SHE SAID THE WHOLE POINT IS TO
MAKE PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE.
IS THAT RIGHT?
SO THEY WERE FOLLOWING YOUR
INSTRUCTIONS WERE THEY?
THE PROTESTERS YOU JUST SAW THE
USE IS PREFERRED TACTICS AGAINST
HER.
THEY SEIZE THE MORAL HIGH GROUND
AND STARTED YELLING.
AND THEY GOT NO RESPONSE FROM
SANDY CRIST SAYS.
BECAUSE SHE HAS NOTHING TO SAY.
THERE ONTO HER AND SHE KNOWS IT.
THE THEY WERE RIGHT.
SHE FUNDED THE LARGEST EXPANSION
OF OUR U.S. MILITARY EVER.
SHE HELPED APPROVE A $37 BILLION
MILITARY BUDGET.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE OUR WHOLE
NATION'S PRIORITY IS TO
SLAUGHTER PEOPLE IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE WORLD.
I THINK IT IS A PRIORITY OF A
POWERFUL AND CONCENTRATED CLASS
IN THE UNITED STATES THAT
HAPPENS TO HAVE A GROUP OF
CONTROL OF OUR GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: SO THAT WAS THE
TIKTOK HE APPROVED VERSION, FOR
THE COLLEGE KIDS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
BUT IN REAL LIFE, SHE DIDN'T
WORD OF IT WERE THE ONLY PART
SHE MEANT WAS THAT AMERICA IS
TERRIBLE.
SHE DOES HATE THE COUNTRY.
BUT PULLING BACK FROM A WAR THAT
WILL HURT THE COUNTRY, WHY WOULD
SHE DO THAT?
SHE DOESN'T LIKE THE COUNTRY.
ANYTHING THAT'S NOT IN OUR
INTEREST SHE IS COMPLETELY FOR.
SO THE SQUAD VOTED TO APPROVE
ANOTHER MASSIVE $42 BILLION
SPENDING BILL.
CORI BUSH EVEN VOTED FOR IT EVEN
AFTER SHE ADMITTED IT WOULD
INCREASE THE RISK OF DIRECT WAR
AND DIRECT MILITARY
CONFRONTATION BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
THE U.S.
SO EVEN CORI BUSH, THE LOWEST IQ
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, KNEW WHAT
SHE WAS DOING.
IT'S GOING TO WAR WITH RUSSIA.
SHE VOTED FOR IT AND THEY ALL
DID.
LEADERS OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ATTEMPTED TO SELL THIS STEP
TOWARD WAR AS A HUMANITARIAN
EFFORT.
WATCH.
>> TODAY WERE VOTING TO PROVIDE
NEARLY $40 BILLION TO ADDRESS
THE IMMEDIATE AND NEAR TERM
SECURITY, ECONOMIC, AND
HUMANITARIAN NEEDS OF THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
>> WE ARE MORALLY OBLIGATED TO
ENSURE THE BRAVE UKRAINIAN
FIGHTERS AND THE UKRAINE PEOPLE
HAVE THE SECURITY AND ECONOMIC
AID THAT THEY NEED.
>> WE'LL BE DOING IS IMPORTANT,
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE.
>> IT'S A DOWN PAYMENT.
IT'S A DOWN PAYMENT ON THE
SECURITY AND SUCCESS OF
DEMOCRACY.
>> GLORIED TO UKRAINE.
WE WANT THE VICTORY FOR UKRAINE.
AND WE WANT DEFEAT FOR
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
REGIME CHANGE WOULD BE GREAT.
BUT WE REALIZE THAT WON'T
HAPPEN.
DEFEAT MUST HAPPEN.
>> Tucker: OH.
SO IT'S HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE.
DID YOU LOOK AT THE BILL?
NO, IT WAS A MILITARY FUNDING
BILL, NOT A MILITARY ASSISTANCE
BILL.
19 BILLION WENT DIRECTLY TO THE
WAR EFFORT IN UKRAINE.
SO, OKAY, IF YOU ARE OUT OF THE
CLOSET NEOCON, IT MAKES SENSE.
BUT IF YOU'RE SANDY CORTEZ,
TALKING ABOUT THE WORKING PEOPLE
FIGHTING THE MAN, WHAT'S HIS
TELL YOU ABOUT HER?
SHE HAS CONTEMPT FOR THE PEOPLE
SHE REPRESENTS.
SHE TALKS ABOUT THEIR MIDGET
STOMACH MISERY ONLY TO LEVERAGE
IT AGAINST THEM.
THEY'RE THE TOOLS OF HER
PERSONAL ADVANCEMENT.
DO NOT THE MEMBERS OF HER REAL
CONSTITUENCY.
NBC AND "TEEN VOGUE" EDITORS,
THAT'S HER CONSTITUENCY.
SHE SHAKING DOWN CONGRESS FOR
MORE CASH EVEN AS OUR OWN
BORDERS OR COLLAPSING.
>> AT THIS TIME WE HAVE TWO KEY
FINANCIAL NEEDS OF THE COUNTRY,
$38 BILLION TO MAKE UP FOR THE
DEFICIT OF OUR BUDGET FOR NEXT
YEAR, AND THE OTHER AND
$17 BILLION THAT WERE VERIFIED
BY WORLD BANK AND NEEDED TO
REBUILD THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE NEED ALSO TO BILLION DOLLARS
TO REBUILD THE ELECTRIC ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE AFTER THE
DESTRUCTION AND TO EXPAND OUR
EXPORT TO EUROPE.
WE NEED CREDIT LIMITS TO
PURCHASE GAS AND COAL FOR THE
FUTURE HEATING SEASON.
THE SCOPE OF THIS YEAR'S SUPPORT
SHOULD BE NOT LESS THAN
$5 BILLION.
>> Tucker: WHAT?
SUM UP THE NEED FOR ORDER AND A
T-SHIRT DEMANDING MONEY FOR HIS
CRITICAL ECONOMIC NEEDS?
WE HAVE CRITICAL ECONOMIC'S TWO
BUDDY.
WHO YOU?
GO AWAY.
SINCE WHEN DOES THIS GUY HAVE A
CLAIM ON OUR TREASURY?
SO THIS IS THE JOB OF PEOPLE
LIKE SANDY CORTEZ.
WE DON'T OWE THIS GUY ANYTHING,
NOT ONE THING.
GOOD LUCK, PAL.
THAT'S IT.
AND AS OUR ECONOMY DEGRADES IN
OUR BORDER IS GONE, THAT GUY IS
LECTURING US WITH SOME CHRISTMAS
LIST, I WANT TO BICYCLE TO A NEW
BETTER SEND IT QUICK.
REALLY WISH MARK UP YOURS,
BUDDY.
TELLING US WE HAVE TO NUKE
RUSSIA PUSH MARK WHAT IS SANDY
CORTEZ DO WISH MARK SHE AFFIRMS
IT.
SHE'S A STEALTHY NEOCON
OPERATIVE, NOT A PROGRESSIVE.
THEY'RE TOTALLY AND UTTERLY
CORRUPT ALL OF THEM IN THE
MOVEMENT.
THE SO-CALLED RADICALS?
THE ATLANTIC, MPR, NBC, TELLING
US HOW MUCH THEY CARE ABOUT
OPPRESSED PEOPLES EVEN AS THEY
CALL FOR A RADICAL RACE WERE
EVERY DAY.
THERE CHEERING FOR THE
APOCALYPSE RIGHT ALONGSIDE THE
PENTAGON.
>> WILL STAY WITH RICK UKRAINE
FOR AS LONG AS IT TAKES.
>> WE WILL NOT WAVER FROM OUR
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORT UKRAINE AS
LONG AS IT TAKES.
>> WE WILL CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
UKRAINE FOR HIS SMALL STOMACH
LONG AS IT TAKES.
>> YOU'RE ALREADY 15 BILLION OR
MORE.
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE?
>> AS LONG AS IT TAKES.
>> Tucker: AS LONG AS IT TAKES
TO DO WHAT?
HOW LONG IS THAT?
WHAT'S THE GOAL?
AND AT WHAT COST?
AND WHAT'S THE RISK WISH MARK
SHOULD WE THOSE?
NO.
AS LONG AS IT TAKES.